elon musk and tesla have diamond hands
when it comes to bitcoin remember last
year they bought 1.5 billion dollars
worth of bitcoin well in a recent
regulatory filing tesla revealed that
their bitcoin is now worth 1.9 billion
dollars that's right almost two billion
dollars in this exact 10k filing that
they put forward this morning tesla has
held on to that bitcoin and they're not
selling they don't care what happens to
the price tesla has diamond hands now if
we dive into the actual filing and we
look at these two quotes tells a lot
about how they're thinking about it
first they said in the year ended
december 31st 2021 we recorded
approximately 101 million dollars of
impairment losses resulting from changes
to the carrying value of our bitcoin and
gains of 128 million on certain sales of
bitcoin by us they then went on to say
that they believe in the long-term
potential of digital assets both as an
investment and also as a liquid
alternative to cash as with any
investment inconsistent with how we
manage fiat based cash and cash
equivalent accounts we may increase or
decrease our holdings of digital assets
at any time based on the needs of the
business or on our view of market and
environmental conditions now this is
important to remember because elon musk
has been asked before how he thinks
about bitcoin and who holds it well
here's exactly what elon said i own
bitcoin tesla owns bitcoin and spacex
owns bitcoin as well elon musk
understands the downsides of fiat-based
currency he also understands why he may
need it for operating costs and to
actually run his businesses but he's not
going to sit by and allow for a
decentralized digital currency with a
finite supply and a programmatic
monetary policy to be created and not
participate a material portion of elon
musk's wealth is in bitcoin and now we
know that almost two billion dollars of
tesla's balance sheet is in bitcoin as
well tesla and elon musk they understand
bitcoin they realize what the value of
it is and they're not selling no matter
what happens to the price they've got
those diamond hands and the fact that
they're talking about fiat based cash
and cash equivalents and regulatory
filings tells you that the tide is
turning culture is changing and
ultimately business owners are having to
wrestle with the question what do we do
when they're seven percent inflation how
do we protect our purchasing power how
do we protect our balance sheet that's
their fiduciary duty and elon musk and
tesla are leading the way for public
companies and making a statement they
own bitcoin they're not selling and that
two billion dollars of bitcoin that's
staying on tesla's balance sheet tesla
and elon musk they got diamond hands
baby